my mom used to be an actress when i was
like when she was pregnant with me and
stuff she did and she was was she known
in brazil not really but i know she did
do like a marlborough's commercial when
she was pregnant with me where she was
like on a horse [ __ ] cigarette and
then you're inside no no no no
please
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
all right support for today's episode
comes from true classic this brand new
sponsor has the absolute best fitting
t-shirts a man can buy upgrade your
wardrobe with true classic at 25 off at
trueclassic.com
with code omg hi free shipping included
on purchase over one hundred dollars 100
risk-free guarantee with a 30-day return
policy just don't return it welcome to
manchester all over stay classy with
true classic your dad bod will thank you
do you drink alcohol
i'm not really some brazilian but i'm a
huge pothead
i didn't smoke today
okay
uh pot head
look let's do let's can you define me
pothead like like what a
a deal i know what a dealer is dealer's
not a pothead no dealers are potheads
too but
that's like a ticket
i'm a hyphen dealer but i'm also a
pothead
but a pothead that wakes up
that's a wake and baker awakened
and they start the day
they wake and bake
wherever are they
that's a good one yeah i've never heard
that before really i have a hat i that
i'd have thought waking bake was
something else well he was in love he
was i like muffins
wake up and bake in bed
making bacon in bed yeah that's what
what is it
having sex in the morning yeah making
bacon yeah
that's the most adorable they used to
have a t-shirt with two pigs uh one pig
on top of that from behind yeah
that was the logo for making bacon and
it's wonderful when you go to church and
you look forward you go you [ __ ]
can't wait
i need that shirt what are you guys
drinking
i have my own beer oh no way so it's
pretty good yes way
is it nice man
are you do you have do you need three i
want to try it
it's it's warm though what happened
what are we
what we're [ __ ] london
ching ching
cheers cheers it's very nice to meet you
um
we're excited to meet you um
no no no no no yeah i have makeup on
it's a big occasion let's start it is
i mean you know you got to get out there
you got to look 90s um okay
let's talk pothead let's talk potheads
um
very serious
just because i like to get to the the
maybe the nucleus of someone's heart you
know what it is i'm scared to take
anxiety medication so i understand okay
okay
um
when did you when did you feel
like you started to have anxiety
oh i can remember the exact day you see
you know you see how that's good you
know my talk show was only two years but
if they would have given me a chance hey
i'd have got down to it we've never met
i know i can't believe we never met by
the way but we're like
yeah yeah because let's talk about that
okay so and now and i don't want to talk
about it in the terms of
the world of anxiety i want to talk
about the terms of yours okay no i'll
tell you the exact day so i moved to
charlottesville virginia when i was 12
from brazil
okay didn't speak english
white town kids were like what's it like
to wear shoes like didn't know where
brazil was okay no they wouldn't know
where brazil was no they didn't know
there's like brazil montgomery alabama
literally yeah like there's like uh
columbia north carolina they know those
yeah
they're all flooded it would have been
something to hold your hooters up
like a like a brazilian [ __ ] chicken
uh the uh
why did you was your father in the
military my dad made holograms he was
one of the pioneers of holography you
know those stickers that were like
three-dimensional he was an artist and
he made those like by hand oh my god
yeah it was really cool so he found this
business partner to open a business in
charlottesville virginia yeah they would
like they would make a sculpture of
something shoot it on a table onto glass
and the gl it would be printed onto
glass
if it's a full butterfly on the piece of
glass and you break it all the little
pieces are the full picture so it's
really a crazy art wow um do you know
that how many millions of people her
father stopped from running through a
[ __ ] glass lighting glass door
[Laughter]
they never used that they started to
float
how many times did you go to somebody's
house and you see [ __ ] when somebody
would hit their forehead running out of
that like just just i say that like a
little watermark at an oil mark over
there or the side of someone's face
i'm coming right out there bam they go
right into the thing and then somebody
said let's etch glass no but it wouldn't
no no the whole no holograms were the
it's the stickers
it's a sticker you know like on your
credit card the little bird yeah that's
what he made yeah
so those stickers those were holograms
but it first beca like you would do it
on glass amazing so then that happened
and there was but that's also a business
where
it's all security [ __ ] it's all security
yeah it used to be art security it used
to be art
the uh you know we met a guy that
invented the swipe of
at the gas stations
the what the credit cards oh when you
just go yeah but if your father's into
that same well he was yeah he was an
artist he wanted to make like and you
know people go over holograms oh like
the tupac and he's like that's a
projection he gets all mad and he's like
it's not the same yeah he said he didn't
do that
when they did that in turn security did
your dad make bank off it did he sell
you know no not really i mean it was the
80s and 90s and then his company
eventually like you know because it all
became machine made they do it all on
computers now he kind of but did he have
a patent for it or did he no no he he
was just one of the first people to do
it like so you know also in those days
if you worked at a company and you
created and you went to your bosses and
you said hey
i have an idea for this thing that you
can put on the back of something and you
can open or you can carry it more
security goes oh i think that's great
then the company would do it
because you're an employee and then they
would make millions of it or split it or
do whatever and then you would be the
employee that got the
maybe got credit maybe not yeah gotcha
they put up a picture of you for a month
and they're like employee of the month
here you go
and then you and then they move you know
they move on and then from that became
the security which i'm sure now is it's
everybody everybody has it on their
credit card yeah it's great because a
hologram when you peel it it like the
sticker never comes off fully so you can
never really replace it so that's that's
awesome okay so so
so remember you remember you remember
when they told you were moving i
remember oh yeah i remember but in the
90s like america was cool like we like
brazil didn't really have an identity at
the time and everything was like america
america i meant you know polly shore
like i was in the west store
yeah yeah it was like you know big
things in america and then we moved to
the states i was already like really big
into dance at the time and there was a
we had a dare production of pinocchio
don't smoke that cigarette it was the
name of the play
because it was like you know trying to
get kids not to do drugs
was pinocchio a little pothead like a
little baby no he smoked cigarettes they
made a little oh he did yeah he was like
really like he was like i'm pinocchio
like it was a whole thing there was a
thing where they were the pinocchio
smoked the cigarette and then you guys
had to talk them down yeah and i was the
lungs i got the part of the lungs
because i couldn't speak english yet i
wanted to play busy body which was like
this other part but i didn't get that
rachel bodily got it and um
what up
she's got kids whatever she's fine she
didn't make it um
but uh give me uh let's show us what a
lung does
well i just i had a dress on and then i
had a little sign that said lungs on it
and the whole thing was pinocchio don't
smoke that cigarette and i was supposed
to go no no no
the guy before me that had that line
messed it up like the timing right yeah
so i panicked and instead of waiting and
going no no no i was just like no no no
no no
and i've had anxiety ever since
is that it yeah seriously
yeah
but the people laughed they laughed they
laughed but i didn't understand that
that was what i wanted to do yet comedy
didn't come to me for a long time i just
was kind of like a goofball but i took
like acting
very seriously so that was not a good mo
like that was not a good moment for me
um
you took acting very seriously who in
your family was was theatrical or
both but my mom used to be an actress
when i was like when she was pregnant
with me and stuff she did and she was
was she known in brazil not really but i
know she did do like a marlborough's
commercial when she was pregnant with me
where she was like on a horse [ __ ]
cigarette and then you're inside no no
no no
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah we're painting the picture and then
um
did you did any friends join you out
from brazil like did they move like this
no i didn't have any friends i remember
a friend came to visit but i was already
like trying to be american trying to be
cool like eat bacon and stuff for
breakfast that was like gross to
brazilian people and she was like you've
changed and i'm like whatever you know
but yeah i wanted to fit in it was just
a very white
like i make fun of it i say that i'm
brazilian
you know because it's brazilian
brazilians eat for breakfast fruit like
nothing really it's not a big they're
very much like birds like in a tree
would get a mango
yeah they can't fly very lightly then
fly to another tree and eat a little bit
they're very light so it's very obvious
i wasn't raised in brazil
yeah
you could pass for brazilian actually
um
okay because i was thinking so okay so
so
the idea that you didn't speak english
because you you you nobody would ever
know now that you know i didn't speak
english yeah my first esl teacher was
russian
i was like who did you boosh to get this
job on it like she could barely speak
english
wow
and i had a really kind of a thick
russian accent when i first started
speaking
all right let us hear it
i was like dodgeball theresa has to try
to beat me
because everybody sounds like you're
hiding in the garage right there i was
like it's just so it was a confusing
time yeah it was a confusing time for me
i just i really wanted to be white and
now everybody thinks i'm white and i
don't want anybody to think i'm white
anymore so
i bleach my personality
it's true
uh okay
i've been around comedy a long time i
bleached my personality maybe one of the
most clever [ __ ] things oh hell yeah
cool yeah yeah i think it's kind of
bleach my personality to blend in
yeah when i was doing my first show the
one of the assistants had a
a a secretary or sister that was german
and they talked you know within they
would say
um we are going to the meeting at noon
george must be there if you want to see
him again
we would always make fun of the dude
that he would because he the writer
robert would say let's call that dude to
hear his voice you got to hear it the
german would come out and they would
come up if you want to see him again
i wish i had an accent i would work so
much more because nobody honestly like
my nationality nobody ever guesses
brazil nobody they're everybody jew
joe everybody thinks i'm a jew from new
york
but that's what i sound like so i guess
they're right
everybody thinks that you do
looking at some of your stuff on youtube
that's what you do sound like i do sound
jewish right you know why because i
loved howard stern and i love fran
drescher when i first started to learn
and i had a lot of friends that i would
go to long island for dance camp so
hofstra i was in long island a lot when
like my formative years you know when
you first start hooking up with boys and
stuff that's when your brain breaks
and so that's
because it's just so much in a short
amount of
words yeah baby i've been up since the
the
the uh okay so how do you find your way
to comedy
i moved out here from emerson wanting to
be an actor wanting to like do hosting
acting stuff i got a job at national
lampoon i remember when they were like
kind of a network
and i was hosting some online show like
a tosh poino style show and the writer
of the show was like you should you
should try stand up you have that kind
of rhythm and i was like i would rather
murder a baby
no thanks but then i went to the comedy
store i had this weird feeling of like
i've been here before like this weird
calling then i started bartending there
like two days after and just started
just jumping did you really feel like
you had built you had found a place
there i had like you know the doors of
the kitchen
i was like i had this weird deja vu like
i've been here before like it was this
very like the building is i i
romanticize it a lot because my dad
loved comedy growing up he was really
into cheech and chong and like you know
andrew dice clay all the
super sweet men out there um
so i think i just kind of wanted to get
his attention and then
i kind of just stick like that because
he was in the house that your father was
loved comedy loved comedy yeah yeah um
i'm going to tell you when i think that
comedy changed into
into apologetic comedy
okay i'm going to tell you when i think
it happened
um
richard pryor never apologized chris
rock didn't apologize
um
did gregory
george carlin
andrew dice clay apologized on arsenio
and started crying did he did and he did
because
should because sinead o'connor and nord
nor done didn't want to be on saturday
night live with them and he went to
arsenio to use it as a platform to
explain himself and he apologized and he
started crying that's crazy and at that
point right there
comedy has never been the same when was
that like the 90s in the 90s
and i love andrew i love i love that the
sweetest guy that's the funniest part
he's so nice but if you look at what
happened before and what happened after
when he apologized
on a national platform like that and
teared up and they laughed and he kept
going
it
made it
it showed the country in the world that
oh if you say something bad we're going
to make you we're going to make you
apologize you became kind of like you
owned it like it became a thing
i think you know i've been in trouble
uh for things that i've said but i don't
apologize in the comedy sense because i
think it's indefensible right it's a
character also right no yeah you can't
it would it would be
like taking a gun away from a police
officer which they said never relinquish
your gun sure
and all of the things that you're not
supposed to do and and for
a comedian
you have it's like that you feel like
the accountability becomes more personal
you've disgraced your art right you know
that that really
disappoints me you know to hear that he
did that
because i was a big fan it changed but
what's the big deal i mean he i mean his
his team probably pushed him to do it
guys i mean you know what i mean it was
probably a
publicity thing to do it just took away
his
they did and you can go back and i mean
we i don't i don't know if we have we'll
ever show the clip but if you go back i
would i'm going to say that i've been
around a long time i've seen a lot of
things i'm a student of of what goes on
right and i believe that that was the
ground zero of comedians apologizing wow
wow so when you slap chris rock you're
not slapping
chris rock you're slapping
comedians
he's ours you're slapping one of the
founding fathers sure i have to admit
though that that week he bumped me a lot
so i was
you would have slapped him before i was
happy
no i would never no i would never harm
anybody physically i'm too much of a
puss yeah will smith just a couple of
days ago came up there was an apology
apology yeah not good enough didn't look
didn't sound good we thought it was that
we were like did we just see that are we
really are we really [ __ ] up i mean it
really happened
but he wasn't really ashamed of what he
did that's very chicano you saw it yeah
they apology i didn't see it yeah
there's a very latino thing you know uh
hey
tell your brother you're sorry yeah uh
tell your brother you're sorry
stepbrother tommy you're sorry
it's always their fault
um
and then you found your way to
but it's not easy to start it's not easy
to start i shouldn't have started at the
comedy store i mean i'm very glad that i
did but i was like you know i i was an
actress i was like come on massage
circles like i wasn't ready for the i
was there in the early 2000s when it was
dark like you know that it was kind of
dead there's not that many people coming
through it wasn't like it is now no no
no no and you know there'd be like four
people one night like the whole night it
would be dead and the only nights that
were really popping were um
tuesdays which was like i forgot what
they called it but it was like the uh
would they call it potluck tuesday no it
was like a tuesday no fat tuesdays flat
tuesdays and it was all the black comics
and that's kind of how i started you
know i would get to watch those nights
and like watch those guys and so i got
to really like study people because at
the time mitzi didn't let women work the
door that's what i wanted to do because
i wanted to learn you know learn but i
would just watch those fat tuesday shows
and what did you see what did you
energetically match me more physicality
um because there's not one thing that
translates in comedy except physicality
really and the way they would tell
stories and yeah just like the energy in
the room and i love like how high energy
it was
which was very different from like the
white dudes that went in the other room
talking about their dicks so i was like
oh cool this this exists as well you
know and there wasn't that many women it
was like whitney who i get compared to a
lot and eliza schlesinger were the only
two women really at the time
to perform and eleanor kerrigan good
company yeah great company but i just
very different from me right they're
they're not did you feel did you feel
there was a
uh uh uh a way that audience responded
to a female comedian
than they would to oh yeah
yeah especially i like i would never
really if i if i dress a certain way or
if i like if i have makeup on if i'm
more dressed up it's harder it's harder
to get where i want to be because people
are like and it's interesting because
you can see women with their guys right
in the audience and the second i tell
like a poop joke or something that makes
me less like [ __ ] they relax
you know what i mean they're like okay i
can laugh now my guy heard her say poop
he's not interested okay so when you're
doing your act you're trying to get
laughs but you're also trying to make
yourself less [ __ ] yes so that the
whole audience will have a good time and
not and not just not because you bought
me naked yeah yeah and that yeah yeah
can you see them thinking about you
naked i can't see it sometimes yeah well
you know when you you feel off you know
when you're not writing you're not on
the wave and then you start to see like
what are these people really think about
isn't it funny how your brain
divides
yeah like you're telling the joke
thinking about the next one looking at
that guy what is this [ __ ] looking at
me like that and you know and it just
all splits and but now you can hear it
you can hear the
in the sound of the audience go down and
now you know when to
could see this dude i could see the
waitress coming down i could see the
person crossing so weird but then this
is the thing we get off stage and then
our brain is like what do we do with
this like we don't really it's hard to
be a human don't you think like when
you're doing comedy all the time you're
like your brain it depends how invested
you become um
you know you can work at a gas station
or you can work out an oil rig
and those are what investments you make
this to me decides how fractured and how
away from people you'll be
if you want to be a real
work in the oil business
you're gonna have to work on the rig
it's a lonely life
it's gonna be lonely and there's gonna
be nights when you're crying and you say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i don't need this [ __ ]
and if you want to have fun and have a
good time you work at a gas station and
you're like hey how you doing good to
see you again bill you get nowhere like
that you have to go and isolate yourself
and be removed from people but i burnt
out man i burnt out last year like that
road yeah it was the first time i really
hit the road by myself really hard and
it was coveted and so i didn't really go
you know i didn't really hang out after
and yeah just in a hotel room and it was
just a lot but i got it all together i'm
finally releasing it yeah
and those days go by so thank you don't
they during the day they do yeah
yeah you're like it's already three but
i want to sleep two more hours
yeah i know i always try to do stuff in
the town you know go like i like i love
second-hand shopping and stuff i love oh
yes yes go find it did your mom ever go
to the goodwill or or salvation army or
anything and get close
no she just stole them
where would she steal them from like
department stores
she didn't uh there were seven of us in
my family really so
she worked my dad worked
uh
didn't go to the second-hand store what
number are you i'm number five
i had four older sisters and two younger
ones
you're the only guy you're the only boy
oh the estrogen no i i and i wasn't
spoiled until i went into the army is
that why you have little that doesn't
matter
they grew in they were like oh we have
to catch up yeah and i can tell because
you're very like well groomed you ever
see somebody with a big nipple but a
small chest like that thing has to grow
oh yeah island nipple
eyelid nipple pepperoni the silver
dollar yeah silver dollar
yeah that's unfortunate that's
unfortunate
okay so hang with you for a long time
you're watching some of your stuff on
the internet now i'm i'm telling you oh
yeah she really is she's much better in
person she gets a little and i got high
approval yeah
you're really really great and and were
as a bartender there were you there when
it closed and you were cleaning up and
and there were very few people in the
comedy store oh yeah some weird [ __ ]
happened late at night there tell me i
saw some weird things that [ __ ] [ __ ]
is [ __ ] in the comedy store because
that used to be cyril's
in the day of frank sinatra punch that
reporter in the main room that used to
be where they used to eat and watch the
show so that place is legendary
uh of sound the energy is incredible i
remember like once that some pipe broke
and there was all these like tiny little
mexicans working underneath the comedy
store they all came out covered in [ __ ]
like covered in [ __ ] and they're all and
i thought oh my god look at all the
famous [ __ ] that they were swimming in
like marilyn monroe's poop
mixed with frank sinatra's
mixed with friends mixed with all the
they were all doing groceries in the 80s
[ __ ] them their brains out
yeah and i thought wow
chain man's feel
better was in there yeah everybody had
pubes
but i wish i lived then i wish i lived
in the area
do you see yourself like i think you
would have been
yeah i think the 80s would have been a
good fit for me i don't know i just i
worship a lot of the women that were
like you know the elaine boozlers and
like those women did you immediately you
met elaine boozler i have never met her
oh no
but there's you know like i there's a
few people if i'm at i feel like i would
be like very nervous
uh tony collette the actress i'm a huge
fan parker posey
and then i get really uncomfortable
around sarah cyril for men i'm always
like you know you're the reason she's
like i know just relax
i just wore i just feel so nervous
yeah oh yeah she's incredible i remember
seeing her special she does a song where
like she puts the mic up to her vagina i
was like it blew my mind like it seems
like such a simple thing but i was like
oh mike i just opened so many doors in
my mind when you gravitated towards
comedians did you more feel comfortable
watching women or were you looking at
everybody actually no i had a really
hard time loving myself as a woman until
like last year
i was like very like bros club like my
early jokes are like i'm making fun of
lesbians a lot and like it's weird it's
i didn't really find my voice until i
think 14 years in
um so you know what i i yeah i'm gonna
say that it takes a while you don't know
nobody finds it immediately i just
didn't know who i was you know and i
wanted to be one of the guy that's who i
only knew bros and you know if you find
your if you think you found your voice
after five years you're using somebody
else's
or you're not digging deep you know
you're just going to say oh i'll be or
you're a good writer and you're getting
laughs from the jokes
yeah yeah but if you're a good writer
and you're
right it depends how much you want to
divulge of yourself i think
yeah and i didn't want to because i
don't think i knew who that was yeah you
know i was still figuring it out and i
think i just like i just didn't see a
lot of women doing because i do music
stuff too and i just didn't see a lot of
people doing it and i was scared to be a
club comic during kind of alternative
right stuff because i really had i just
went towards um making money quicker you
know i didn't want to do the alt rooms
as much and i also felt like i was too
dirty for the alt rooms so i didn't
really feel like there was really a
place and i think that comes from
feeling like the immigrant thing you
know yeah i'm not really fully american
i'm not really
sorry did somebody did somebody say to
you that uh we won't keep you long gil
did someone say to you that uh
that's like a comedian uh
that they thought you were too blue or
whatever the dirty word or whatever i
would get too blue all the time too
dirty all the time
all the time because because in uh in my
day
in my day back there when you were
starting you were a facade you had to be
clean because if you were dirty they
just would say that guy's dirty uh x
out so you try to be funny clean and
then when you got a little more
comfortable you started to become more
adult
but the initial
turn off was
being blue they would say you're blue
yeah i definitely get so so if you were
blue
that they would say oh he works blue and
then you're immediately discounted from
almost like opening this door and seeing
this world i definitely wish yeah i wish
i wrote like i i actually just took a
comedy class like i i did it kind of for
my ego you know just to
relearn re game explain to me what that
was before the ego was recorded well
because i was like i've been doing this
for a long time i do this for a living
already
this is my 14th year okay
so i was just like but i never really
learned structurally like kind of really
bright bits right and i wanted to work
clean i really want to and i was having
a hard time sitting down by myself to do
it so i just challenged myself to take
this class and hearing other people do
bits that weren't there yet and being
able to fix them taught me so much i
learned so much and now i finally i'm
submitting to late night for the first
time but you know after 14 minutes to
late night so you have to do a five
minute clean set i've never been able to
do that before
new sponsor alerts support for today's
episode comes from true classic the
brand new sponsor has the absolute best
fitting t-shirts a man can buy
finding the right t-shirt with a little
bit of a dad bod is incredibly
frustrating almost all men's t-shirts
are designed to look good on skinny
models with six packs but most of us
aren't packing anything but a few beers
so fellas they're wearing the wrong
clothes true classics tees they taper
off towards the bottom so they fit
tighter around the chest and shoulders
and it's time to highlight your best
attributes with a t-shirt you can always
confidently throw on
i love mine i'm wearing it right now
it's been one of my favorite shirts from
the moment i got it
uh you know they gave us something to
take back and
um everything you know everything about
a t-shirt for me because i do own
uh tons of them
is almost like when you throw
something you know if a pizza maker was
going like this he would know in the
second spin that that particular thing
you'd have to start again with t-shirts
and me when i put them on they kind of
hit your shoulders and as they go down
you that's where you make your decision
oh this is nice and that's what i got
when the true classics at the house they
feel good when they first go on it's
about time you learn how to dress
yourself properly upgrade your wardrobe
with true classic get 25 off a
trueclassic.com with code
omghi free shipping included on purchase
over 100
100 free risk guarantee and a 30 day
return policy stay classy with true
classic your dad bod well thank you i
know my bot thanks i've been buying
these things and i love them all right
take it easy pokemon we're the
commercials over
[Music]
that's a very very good point is that
you could fix something you know um a
lot of people drive cars and then have
great analogies a lot of people drive
cars but they can't be mechanics and
then you bring it in you say turn it on
let me hear it okay i know what's wrong
with it and that's somebody that would
tell you have gone to a comedy class so
you think it made you a better
structured computer made me a better
writer maybe a better writer because i
can always fake it you know i'm a
performer like i can always make some i
do impr i did improv for so long i could
always come up with something make fun
of an audience member get a laugh
yeah but i didn't understand like
you know what it was i was scared to
work on something and have it be
rejected
it was easier to go i just came up with
this [ __ ] them but now that i'm like no
that i know this works before it even
hits the stage very honest you know so
it's amazing
and and
do do the things come to you like if
you're driving and then you come to you
and then you're like oh at night and
they and they place themselves yeah at
night i'm like do you get that does your
brain turn on and the second i hit the
sack i'm like
you know yeah so i keep a notebook by
the bed and then coming to los angeles
did you where did you where did you have
any money you had money saved i had no
money i had 100 and 130 000 in student
loans when i moved to l.a
you know
when you have when you when you become a
student
i don't know how this country is
structured set up where you're playing
you'll be somebody that's 75 [ __ ]
years old and they go when i die i'm
gonna leave you with a house what about
your student loan son of a [ __ ] i
literally still [ __ ] all that money
[ __ ] hey it [ __ ] never goes away
like you know biden or anybody saying
i'm gonna wipe out student loans it's
almost like
the irs said okay scientology is a
religion
when i was working in 1988
at in in las vegas at the maximum i made
750 a
a week i would walk across the street to
the am pm and i would get a usa today
two cheeseburgers out of the heating
lamp doritos and a diet coke and that
was my meal for the day oh my god i kept
it under five dollars i was at five
dollars a day
what did you what was and then also
i met some actors in the early 80s and
one of them was in a very famous movie
and when i went over there they were all
sitting at the coffee table looking down
i'm like what the [ __ ] are they looking
at and they were looking at change
and they were looking to see how much
they needed to buy a box of kraft
macaroni and cheese
and milk
they don't want to use water they were
trying to get milk you know water yeah
and i mean you know i still work during
the day and i gave him a [ __ ] ten you
thought hey can we also dick or what
should we just go one sec one at a time
i took out ten dollars out of my wallet
i gave it to them and they cri they
couldn't believe i said no
keep it
and they couldn't believe it and they
took the money that girl left and and
went to go buy milk and and stuff and
poor trauma man it never goes away i
still have it what did you what did you
where did you go how did you survive i
we ate at the comedy store a lot people
would bring food to the back and we'd
all kind of share it so i would go to
joe's pizza because i used to do this in
boston i would go to joe's pizza after
their clothes and all the pizzas they
were on display they didn't sell they
would give to us
so we'd all share the pizza from joe's
pizza and then
cut too many years later i didn't
when i lived in boston there was a pizza
place right at my school
yeah i mean
not like the mance is doing the creepy
crawl through the huge dumpsters in the
back yeah yeah they don't know
until we talk the guys smart wow and
then you know many years later i did the
soup i hosted the soup and my billboard
was right across from joe's so it was a
moment for me it was a moment right i
would go and eat pizza and cry and look
at my huge crotch it's amazing on sunset
they made it very so large
did they it was your vagina i was
wearing very high
very high pads huge camel toe yeah my
name wasn't on it but you could like see
my [ __ ] recognize it yeah you people
could recognize you said you could see
your [ __ ] from the billboard yeah
beautiful if we could put up a photo
when we put this episode up it's
beautiful gil said beautiful it was
beautiful now i've had with me i've had
camera tone
um
how i was heavier in your defense
uh and but when you have it do you know
you have it is it is it a rocket is it a
ploy i rock it you just got to make sure
the lips are split so that it's not one
heavy on one side yeah because you can
have two lipsticks no you could squish
on one yeah yeah
i like to say that i like my lips
separate but equal
that's so gross
but you know you have to have a [ __ ]
worthy of having campbell there's a lot
of [ __ ] out there but a lot of them i
don't want to see candlestone what do
you mean i think you're i don't know
women you are worthy
companies are showing now the camel toe
i knew a lady that had camel toe from
the top of her butt to the back of the
to the [ __ ] belt
it was like a [ __ ] cesarean coming
wait that's an elephant toad it was a
full um
yeah they're showing it more because
women are owning it more because we put
a lot of shame in our vagina there's a
lot of shame that we carry there
you know
and it is ain't no shame to your game
but there is some shame uh there is some
shame in your game that's a little shame
in the game it's a little shame you
can't push the envelope if there's no
shame in your game yeah otherwise every
girl would already be rocking camel toes
on billboards yeah you know but there
were some pants that
since you're very comfortable with your
camera i think some dittos would have
been awesome on you what are dead ditto
no did all pants were in the early 80s
and set late 70s and they had no pockets
oh i know they're really high and they
were high
and they're coming back and they had no
pockets so it was all cool so
wait and they would make wait isn't cool
but but like ass oh i said it would show
like that but it made it made a woman's
ass looked like
it was it was it was just full black it
was
high-waisted pen aren't those spandex
and when they do the yoga the yoga pants
no no spandex no i know you're talking
about they're like high-waisted 70s and
the the thing would go all the way up so
yeah those are kind of coming and then
the the ad was a girl like all her
weight on the left yeah i say the button
one big butt cheek my girlfriend had
uh had some of those they were yeah but
do you think it's possible for women to
be funny and then that sexuality to be
completely gone you know what i mean
you would like to think that i'm sure as
a country we're not that pro we're not
that progress but it would be okay if
you could remove
that tension of my man laughing
uncomfortable laughing and just laugh
and not think about every single [ __ ]
thing that's said but if you're funny
you're funny dude laugh or don't realize
yeah yeah i don't want them to think i
want them to like escape for that moment
immediately
yeah you know they just say childbirth
is the worst thing a woman could ever do
we go you ever get your dick caught in
the zipper that's [ __ ] hurt
and it's [ __ ] it hurts like a
[ __ ] when you it's like having
kids you can tell exactly when the
contraction started i zipped my dick up
one time in high school and
it's never been the same ever again
because remember you have to zip it down
almost like something about there you
have to you have to
ugh
i tried to live with it just captured
the tip but it can't
be scary you're not wearing your
baseball did it scar you for life
it hasn't been easy
uh he's recovered he's doing fine his
dick's fine all of those things that
you're like more accidents happen in the
household yeah of course zippier but you
know how guys do that thing where they
pull out a ball and they're like check a
chewing gum and people are like haha
if i pulled out
vagina lip and was like look out my
leather wallet
we're not there yet look at my carton
first
it's real leather it's italian and then
open it up yeah yeah people would you
know you can't what's in there there's
we don't have that yet like more women
get to be like raunchy and funny in that
way where there's no sexuality that
hasn't happened yet that hasn't unless
you know sometimes when you're like
maybe
i don't this sounds [ __ ] up but when
you're a girl in
less [ __ ] [ __ ] that sounds [ __ ] up
can we cut that
but
you think no no i think i think um
because you think that somebody has to
it has to be a surprise that somebody
would be less [ __ ] and they would
say things and then you would be like oh
[ __ ] they said something that can't uh
uh that can't be part of their life
they're saying it because i think they
can get away with it a lot more
than than
than i can yeah but i'd like to get away
with it because that's how i am with my
friends and we think but i think i think
that as your success grows and people
come to start to see you and the rooms
get bigger that you will be allowed to
be able to to swim in your own pool yeah
it's cool to do the hour when people
come to just see you that power it's
very exciting you can you write yeah all
five people love the shows
i love your analysis you know you said
you're you're good at analogy you did
the car thing around
when people come and you have you're
able to swim in your old pool that's
right when did you start comedy when did
you start stand up come on swimming in
your own pool is the difference between
in summers when you try to get 35 cents
for your mom to go
and swim with a bunch of other [ __ ]
more costumes oh 35 cents i know when
you started
they would put the comedy and then you'd
have to put that pin on your hands yeah
yeah on your swimsuit and then go and
open it up um like a bracelet and the
spasm you know the little
i started comedy in on in june 4th 1979
i was remember the date
i was still in high school and it was
here in l.a right it was at the comedy
store in westwood stop that doesn't even
exist anymore huh it's an italian
restaurant yeah and across the little uh
it's a like la bruschetta and across the
way there there was a uh
there there was a light
there was an arcade in a small little
place
so the guys would and girls would be
playing pinball and they would come and
they'd go hey one more and then you and
then you'd go okay here take the thing
and you would slide into the game and
continue the game while that person went
and did a spot
that's so crazy and la jolla you would
do all those and stuff like that
too right and the deli smoker on ventura
and the la cabaret
and then i was i was around when disco
was still going on and they did thank
god it's friday at oscar's disco on
la cienega and there was a
club there in the middle of the night
and who was like your influence like who
as a kid we like who was the first
person you performed with that you were
like oh my god like this is the
the first person that i performed that
you were like so star struck from
um
bill hicks i think
i shared a dressing room with bill hicks
and that was like 88 chaos
it's amazing it makes me nervous amazing
i saw him in in the early 90s i saw bill
hicks in chicago at the funny firm and
there was maybe 12 people there on a
wednesday and he did his act like if
there was 1200 people there and i was
like you got it right
he didn't [ __ ] around he was all
business with 12 people there and i said
to him is that difficult he goes no not
when you're
doing your act
and you're not trying to
make 12 people sound like
120 people see that's the difference
between performing and writing do your
work that's the difference
it takes a lot of work to have a good
joke and people don't get that people
think oh i'm on youtube i got the i can
headline no
no no
a lot of a lot of clubs you know when
you see you would see somebody like um
you know that kid leo gonzalez that was
in here yeah that made his ticket
did he did he make his
way talking about me did he make his
identity
well i don't know him is he a tick tock
guy i just started getting on tick tock
uh for a long time i didn't think
i didn't think anything was really funny
anymore he said and i've been at it for
over a decade starting on youtube and
now defunct vine then life happened and
he stopped
in
2020 he made an account
and
it inspired him once i remember how
funny things are i was just like this is
what i feel the most comfortable doing
the 27 year old comedian from hanford
california can deliver a spot-on
impersonation of george lopez looking at
a menu oh he's your impersonator i see
so that's his thing he's a kid and he's
and he but he started in comp he did his
ten years long time to be grinding it
out
he wasn't on
stage so yeah he was on stage i i would
say i i think leo is great i think leo
is great he made his
he may talk about other comics during my
interviews he made his identity
he made his identity doing me but that
[ __ ] couldn't stand on stage for
10 minutes
and and not have a camera that not be
doing selfies or live lives that happens
a lot these tick tock people book these
huge roles or they're like you know and
sometimes it's like it doesn't translate
but a lot of them have already done all
that stuff by the time they get to
tick-tock and then you have extra and
then you have comedy club owners that
are [ __ ] that only want to fill the
room and then they bring a couple of
tick-tockers in there with a screen and
they try to use a laser pointer and
after 20 minutes they're all [ __ ]
done
but the show's not even an hour long
because they can't
make [ __ ] happen this is their big thing
and when it doesn't work
right they have a gimmick like you yeah
you put your out you put your hours in
yeah you got to put them who did you
work with that you thought that
you know i worked with kevin nealon for
many years i learned a lot from him but
like my main guy that i would say my
my all my style is based on is bobby lee
which is so funny because he's just so
crazy um he's insane um but i was on the
road with him for like seven eight years
you know bobby lee um
is uh
uh i did my first podcast with george
bobby league bobby i think that
[ __ ]
but also there's guys out you know you
know all the guys that are [ __ ]
juniors you know he's a genius and i
learned a lot from him but he's another
guy that will not do a special because
he's a pro he doesn't want to waste the
material because also
there's part of you that
if you blow up a balloon you have to
blow it all the way up you can't blow it
up halfway and those dudes go all the
way in like he'll he'll sit there
[ __ ] naked
and do a podcast or wear a thong
or
mine my daughter told me that
they did the hot wings thing and he [ __ ]
on himself because of the hot
like during the day
during the interview he goes oh and then
i want that freedom see i want that
freedom
and didn't run off he sat there
he's got so many great he's just such
he's so [ __ ] really really really
watching him i learned so much about how
he gets in his own way
like you know you you watch even bill
burt he'll come off stage i didn't do
that thing i wanted i'm like bill you
just did two hours like you watch how
our demons get
you know control us so much and if we
could just let go
because it's healthier the demons
you're
you're accountable for the demons but
the demons don't tell you what to do
you're trying to impress them and then
when you come off you go i didn't do
that [ __ ] thing and yeah it's not and
it's not for you it's for
your
yeah like you can have the best
everybody's like you killed and you're
like no but i did it didn't feel good to
me like something was off like it didn't
feel right so so so how did you get the
soup the soup i uh because the soup is
legendary it's called talk soup remember
talk soon
yeah very cool you know
it was a very short-lived thing because
of covid and because of timing but um
i was uh doing mostly acting stuff i
just had a sitcom that got cancelled and
what was the sitcom it was called um
manhattan love story it was on abc
it was i mean i a lot of funny people
but i think they just i don't know it it
was what did you feel what did you feel
about it i loved it i thought everybody
was really funny it just i think was
like a random kind of storyline you
could hear the main two characters
thoughts and it was like a romance
comedy
and it was at the same time as a and z
and blackish and those took off and ours
just didn't have a place i think but it
was it had all the
i had all the things it needed for a
successful sitcom i just didn't make it
and i just moved to new york it was a
big drastic change and
um i didn't want to do hosting stuff
because there was that part of me that
was like hosting but i'm an actress you
know and i have a great agent she was
like do this hosting thing was a show
with nick cannon
um where we make fun of celebrities
social media really good idea
and i had nothing to lose so i was
really myself and nick was amazing
really led himself to the show and we
shot it as a pilot and tried to sell it
to e and that was kind of my audition
tape you know we didn't know that they
were looking for a host for um the soup
at the time but that kind of showed them
you know my range and what i could do on
my feet and then it just it was just so
much pre-production you know interviews
and then five episodes in covet hits
so it was rough it was a it was very
emotional for me to get over it uh it is
yeah you know it is something huh yeah
when you're doing something and then
yeah it was hard and because i couldn't
really even talk about it being over
because they didn't want us to talk
about it
and uh so i never really got that
closure what was your emotion
i was up i was pissed because i kind of
went with like i was just yes and yes
and yes and second season second season
and then i never really got to make it
mine and so i was frustrated with myself
that it went that way right um there was
just a lot of notes all the time and i
you know your hand's too high
it was and i didn't really i didn't
really feel like myself
um so this new show
is me but you know what that's a good
one to to you know it's almost like
making pancakes you burn one
and you're your first that's a big one
that i burned and you burned i burnt it
you burned it but also you it made you
better for the future i learned a lot i
learned a lot and i was it was just such
a big shoes to fill and people were so
pissed that it wasn't joel you know so a
lot of it was just me being like i'm
different than joel right natural
um
but you were good at it but i think i
was good at it i love reality tv so it
came really easy to me we had a great
writer's room god they just let us do
what we wanted to do i know but you know
what that's that's the thing that they
don't let you do
if they just let us go
just hire the people you believe in and
let them be the people you want them to
be you know instead of trying to put
them into a box and but yeah so that's
the show that i'm promoting now hotties
is coming out they just were like go it
was me in another comic writing jokes on
the spot and they were like great great
great they just and where can people
were people it's on hulu august 16th it
comes out called hotties yeah yeah
hotties
hotties
and and it's about uh is it uh is it
like that it's a hybrid no it's a hybrid
dating cooking competition show that i
just and i just make fun of the dates
and then throughout it we feed them
spicy stuff so they're like so they're
also [ __ ] themselves thrown up
super hybrid is it blind date is it
blind date stuff blind date you know
it's a wonder that they haven't said
sight impaired date like what it's still
blinding
i was like excited near near
you couldn't use blind you couldn't say
you're blind
yes you can
what you can't say to someone that's
blind you're blind
what that's like a little person thing
um
i don't know it depends who's around
there's no there's no good what do you
mean
blind is just how you describe it it's
not offensive no good housekeeping seal
of comedy like one person will be
watching and go i'm blind
have you ever done a show
i'm bad
person in the front row wearing
sunglasses and you're making fun of them
and then you're like oh you're blind
you realize as you're making fun of them
one time this lady was native american
and uh
and i said uh
what an international you know i'm
native american and then she was with
her husband i said what i'd be buying
your drinks
and they both got up and left they did
yeah
what's have you had any other thing like
that where people got so pissed
like nobody's ever i think nobody's ever
thrown anything at me
but they've gone they've left
and
you want to walk some people because you
can't keep everybody in there you gotta
you know you got i haven't gotten there
yet you got to walk some people like you
know
if you're cooking the the pot when it
gets really hot the [ __ ] lid comes
off and that [ __ ] starts flying that's
what you want you want some people to go
[ __ ] this [ __ ] dude
and uh i'm just starting to feel that
way yeah isn't that funny that it took
me that i wanted to please everybody you
know
but you're in the right you're in the
right amount of time i'm happy for you
because that's it's free that's when the
freedom it comes it's just starting to
come so hotties we're going to we're
going to watch we're not done but
hotties are going to yeah it's good it's
a bunch of hot people like kissing each
other and
throwing up and stuff
[Laughter]
on the show yeah
can you can a hot person fall in love
with someone who's who
remembered like love at first sight and
they would say like the guy was trying
to make this girl into someone she
wasn't
and he he was he felt he was like how do
you know the [ __ ] guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i love i didn't see that
season as much but i saw it and it was a
demotion of him for his eyes to be with
this woman but then he was trying to
make it work but he was [ __ ] so rude
and mean it was
critically like mean to her [ __ ]
heart about the way she did look like a
cracked [ __ ] bird but wait are you
i'm thinking about somebody else because
the asian girl is really cute that's who
i'm thinking about that's who he was
with
i think and she was trying to give it
away but her personality was like i
don't know
her personality was like remember she
said i'm trying to have kids her
personality she watched it he like knows
details you hear that personality was
like she was trying to give the [ __ ]
away and nobody
because she was so wanted out there he
never ceases to amaze me in all this
[ __ ] she watches i want to have a
reality show where you where you make
people the more sex they have with each
other the more points and the more money
they make at the end let's do it
together nobody will buy it let's do it
together
right george lopez jade cut up right on
who's gonna [ __ ] the most yeah who the
uh
we got it's tgim
um
but there's a freedom and all of that i
love your bag too by the way thanks um
and are you you're married right mm-hmm
oh you're not married no not married i
thought you were married no no just
dating hot guy oh yeah where did you
meet this hot guy i made fun of him on
the soup he was on a reality show
do we know who he is no he's like he's a
finance guy and he just was on a reality
show like he was on hinge and some
casting director was like do you want to
do reality did you watch hinged no
explain to gill because guilt because
gil stole see this is him he'll still
wait
friend who was on the soup she's like
you're going to think he's so dumb and
you're going to want to [ __ ] him i was
like i do think both of those things
but then he turned out to be a super
smart great guy i was never really easy
on the ice but no woman ever said you're
going to think he's really dumb and
you're going to want to [ __ ] him
you don't know that you don't know that
you don't know that that might have got
[ __ ] doesn't come to your face i may
have been my dick's worst enemy
because i would have talked myself out
of it the dick's like we can [ __ ] uh
no we're not
you know your mind is good you're not
married were you married
i was married
for
17 years
my age
this is married none of us are married
see but i wear a ring on the finger it's
bad luck huh but it was my grandma's
if something bad like it was your
grandmother's okay good thing if you got
a knott's berry farm that bad [ __ ] would
have you get hit by a [ __ ] car
if you buy a license plate knott's berry
farm you're gonna [ __ ] die in a
tragic accident
or any or if you buy anything from
cracker barrel you heard it you got you
got a year and a half left but i like
those rocking chairs i don't [ __ ]
care
the food is actually a rocking chair
kicks ass until you're in it for 40
minutes and you're like wanna go inside
baby you're like mother [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was i the better nails what the
[ __ ] rocking chairs he's been married
for 51 years stop
where's your ring
it's right there right
it just went into the boat it just went
into this
evaporator yeah
it's around his heart one years what's
the secret
[ __ ] god sleep with other people what is
that
she's much kinder than i am that's why
she's much more understanding yeah he's
very very lovely one she's the glue that
keeps everything yeah he's the glue i'm
the spaz yeah so am i the anxiety and
it's was he was he what your friend said
you're gonna think he's so dumb is he
dumb he's not dumb at all like i
remember the first time he reached out i
made some joke about like shaving his
armpit hair some joke dumb joke and he
was like i'm more aerodynamic dynamic
now i shaved it thanks i was like oh he
knows the word aerodynamic okay and that
was the beginning and then it was
covered so we were face timing you know
how hot it is when a girl sees you shave
under your arms and then she goes that's
aerodynamic and you go oh he knows where
aerodynamic i mean that's i was
interested you guys laughed a lot
together huh yeah we laugh a lot there
was a video of me making fun of on tv
and then it cuts to me like shaving his
butt it's really funny like
um but he's just been yeah he's a sweet
patient guy because you know we are nuts
people the industry just keeps us kind
of never comfortable so
you need somebody who's more of a yang
you know more of a chill
and uh um
yeah interesting and he's in finance
which is a shitty place to be right now
because because we're in a weird place
and and uh how did you guys what was
your guys first date like you reached
out to each other but not on instagram
like no it was he reached out on twitter
but i wasn't running my social media at
the time so i reached out to him as well
and then we just started facetiming and
then the first time we met was like 90
day fiance style at the airport but i'm
the brazilian so
uh switched things around and uh then
our first trip was like here during
covid and it was like everything was
closed
we went to like the poppy fields that
was our first date remember you know you
ever go yeah it's cute
and and um
what how what's
what's the
what's the timeline now do you think
it's
a shorter amount of time that people
fall in love
yeah i think people fall in love quicker
faster right yeah i think faster i think
you know right away what you're looking
for too i think we're more conditioned
to know and where does that come from
tv
how romance looks on tv maybe or the
fear of dying alone because the world's
ending
one of those what do you think i don't
know i i i don't know i'm i'm just you
know we're with you
do you remember when you asked around
years after oh yeah how did you ask her
out
i said do you mind if i send my covered
wagon over to you
did you send a pigeon
i met her i knew her before i asked
before we actually went out
i was playing in a band her young he was
playing in a band her younger brother
was like a young stevie wonder he's a
keyboard guy we brought him in there you
go she used to drive him she became a
groupie of the band and that's how we
got to know and then it was was he
younger also blind no you know he was
okay okay okay cool cool that's what i
was going through
that's when we started seeing each other
and then it started
just growing from there so so when you
saw her there immediately like you guys
were like hey it was cool huh yeah it
took time we had a friendship and then
it built from there and i was only at
the time i was only when i first met her
i was only 15 years old oh my god and
then
16 and then at age 17 i went into the
army
oh and then i went to vietnam and then
she dumped my ass she was in vietnam
went to vietnam 17 people are doing tick
tocks mad about not making money
i just turned i went into the army at
17. i turned 18 november 29th february
1st i'm in vietnam
scorpio
sagittarius oh okay nicer
and or i say feces but my friends call
me number two so
i i went to vietnam when i was in
vietnam she dumped my ass
[ __ ] dumped him in vietnam
oh it was so rude could it be a worse
could you
like worse just wait man like and then
like you go to the electric chair before
they hit the switch by always honey by
the way it's not working it's not
working
so when it came out you read the let you
still have the letter
no she found it she felt recently she
got rid of it
she found old letters where she wrote
the letter did you get rid of it why
should you get rid of it
because when i came out it was like
sexting so they were probably like no no
no no sexy that is what it is
that was sex dino yeah in 49 days you're
gonna see me and i'm going to take off
my slips i'm going to give you that
everybody that is sexy [ __ ] right in
the letter writing letter i'll see you
and when da nang falls yeah i can't when
i came out i had i all i want to do is
hook up with her and then dump her ass
like she dumped me i wanted revenge i
got out in june by september after
eating out of the palm of my hand and
december 26 the day after christmas we
got married do people still spite [ __ ]
people yes yeah i hate [ __ ] yeah yeah i
hate [ __ ] there's also pity [ __ ] too
yeah or you just like [ __ ] someone to
give him your stds if you really hate
him
[Laughter]
[Music]
one time i did go on stage
after damn cook was on and i was like i
just want to [ __ ] him to give him
everything i got
so different times the rest is history
yeah so
51 years 51 years
what's your average what do you guys
still have a vivid sex life
not as vivid as i'd like it to be
it's not baby it's faint
watercolors yeah it's black and white
anything your dad would draw no no it's
not 3d um that's beautiful though just
being together that long it's part of is
part of the dating thing now too to to
progress to
um
living together or or
well he doesn't live here it's long
distance still so he goes in and uh you
know in and out
yeah well i'm pan i'm pansexual so i'm
open to all
colors shapes sizes is that what that is
pansexual means like you know bisexuals
you're attracted to men and women
pansexual means like you don't care
you're just like
i mean i'm not gonna like a [ __ ] [ __ ] a
tree or anything but like
if you have like if you went twice have
you tried a tree yet not yet but uh
whatever you went through there's been a
couple times i took mushrooms and i was
like that's pretty [ __ ] sexy if you
went to la county fair like everyone's
in play there everyone's in play
everyone is in play yeah the guy on
stilts yeah
especially yeah i'll be standing up so i
got his dick he'll be just
he's still throwing up
the kids are everywhere
cool uh yeah is uh
uh you want to have kids i do i want to
have kids and it's getting and you're
getting interested
i'm 38. two maybe three i'm 38 so it's
getting to the point where i'm like oh i
gotta have some kids soon but you know i
know there's so much stuff i want to do
still you know
you're 38 years old 38
i would not i would have known
oh my gosh thanks guys i would have not
i would have not said i would have not
said
i mean so much fun like nobody does that
yes nobody would do that they would turn
around go turn around it's fine my mom
used to get dressed in front of me she
turned around i said listen i don't want
i didn't want to look at the front of
the first place
well how many people are in your family
like what how many siblings i'm an only
child okay yeah never knew my father i
wasn't raised with my mother and i'm
estranged from my biological family
so wait wait say that slower i i don't
communicate with anyone in my biological
family wow
and uh did you ever want to or was there
a moment that made it no no and then
i
never knew my father and my mother's
still living and we haven't spoken in
in years do you want to do you feel like
you should no
well you know it's funny i think about
her passing away and
it's just so much time has passed and so
much pain that but so what
don't you want to just no what you could
develop a whole new relationship i don't
want to there's a new sitcom there i
just want to golf yeah there is a new
sitcom there where you reconnect with
your mind
with my real daughter
that's amazing how many kids
so one in one you did the same thing one
and one yeah and uh so we sold the show
to nbc premieres the november fourth and
awesome moments
it's so hard to sell a show it's hard to
be taken not to jewish mazel
uh i love muscle too by the way yeah and
and um
and it's about our relationship after
the divorce wow
so i would love to audition for that so
let me know
you know what i would love for you to
be on the show that's amazing you know
what it's like this one i know
collectively like
you know al madrigal is my best friend
on the show people love it we sent eric
griffin you know i love those guys
angela johnson i sent i told you i'm
never better isn't that crazy but but i
know but like like but you know
there's people that you just run into
and you just like you know i i you know
the first show i was green as green can
come at the first show and we managed to
make it stay it's been around 20 years
it's so it's still rolling
i mean it's just so hard to get anything
on air it's people don't understand how
difficult it is like what how many
stages it has to go through you know and
even when you book something you can
still get fired you know and or replace
like
so there's so you know going and doing a
show it's like you're you're waking up
walking on
uneven ground every day
like
we didn't know if we were staying six
shows 60 shows
to enjoy whatever 160
just have to and i would tell him you
know let's have fun and then you know i
became friends with all the people that
i admired growing up like cheech and
chong were were good friends of mine you
know are good friends of mine and i golf
with cheech and oh my
so he said the first time i bat you hit
a home run nobody does that
and he put his arm around me [ __ ]
thing i just want to get so high with
him oh it's gonna get so [ __ ] let me
tell you a good story yeah so teachers
like i met teaching i had it this was
like probably early 2000s had a
convertible poor silver porsche it was
there in my beard we have any more of
this is it waitress or is there a
waitress around him
and uh so true story so he's like hey
come down
so
we i go to his house on a sunday
afternoon and he lives in malibu in the
sun's setting
and he says you want to
go up to the top
and the the sun's going to come down and
we he and i smoke weed as the sun is
going down
at his at his house and i'm looking at
my [ __ ] idol smoking weed back and
forth and he walked down that ladder and
the thing it took me about 20 [ __ ]
minutes to put my foot down
and then we went inside and we ate and i
was still high we swept a little bit and
he was like all right i'll see out of
this car
and he had a gate that would open but
you had to go up to the gate you know
and i said i'll see you later man hugged
him and he went in there he's gonna take
a bath all this to go to bed and about
25 minutes later he said he walked by
the window and he saw my car and he's
like what the [ __ ] is that out there and
my car was out there
and he i was sitting out there for 25
minutes thinking that the gate was gonna
open
but it hadn't opened and i'm like is it
moving is it not moving five minutes am
i too close and he knocks on what the
[ __ ] he goes you gotta get closer to the
gate
i was [ __ ] about 50 [ __ ] yards
from the gate
yes
he was going to bed he walked by the
window what the [ __ ] is that how long
have you seen it i was so hot longer
because i saw it opening and yeah and i
just i never the gate never opened but
to me
it was moving but i was still so i was
so high good weed man
when there's like a police siren in the
song you're listening
in the rap song a [ __ ] kid on a bike
a police on a bike
i just
i mean i that's where i want to live in
malibu so bad i'm addicted to the beach
i drive out there probably once or twice
a week just to go hang out you know i
think you can manifest your destiny yeah
i want to get out of echo park i just
love it but there's too much trash
that's your destiny yeah yeah if you
imagine i've imagined things that have
happened very profound thank you yeah so
so i grew up watching chico in the man
1973 so
and freddie prince jr and i became
friends and
freddie prinz was my idol growing up
like really
so specific
loved him yeah and
he passed away in like uh january 28th
of 1977 a week after he did the
inauguration for jimmy carter
and i remember when i got up in the
morning
i was getting ready to go to 10th grade
and they said that he had shot himself
and i sat at the edge of the bed with my
little mouth open like in my first time
for my life
for like 20 minutes
like what the
what
and then you know he passed away and
then
um
uh
i i
when when my show was going to like the
100th episode
which was already
unimaginable incredible yeah and johnny
grant the unofficial mayor of hollywood
says to me i was at steve edwards that
used to be on good day la star ceremony
yeah and he said to me
um
i think it's about time that we think
about putting you into the hollywood
walk of fame and i would go as a kid and
look at the names and i would imagine
that george burns
said george lopez
we would go for the summer every day at
10 30.
and they would go come on and i would
look at george burns and see
so to get in a situation where that guy
because he he hosted all the ceremonies
and he said uh i think you should think
about putting you into the and i said
i'm not going in until freddie prinze
goes in
and he looked at his assistant and you
know she has the clipboard up like this
and he's like i think freddie is in i
said no i don't think he's in and then
he said well
i said but i'm not going in unless he
goes in [ __ ] so he said well let let us
check and we'll see and i said he i said
he's not so so they call a week later
and they say he's not in
and i and they said but if you would
like him to be in you could sponsor him
in
and you could you could pay the the
thing to get him in
i want to know how much that is at that
time it was ten thousand dollars oh my
gosh and i said uh um i'll do it
and i had the ceremony
for freddy friends um
before i had mine and uh it is one of
the things if not the thing that i am uh
the most proud of proud so beautiful
that's so beautiful are you showing us
oh my god look at that holy [ __ ]
that is so crazy
oh that's so cool you see that going
what check this out this is uh
and then
scroll down and then his is that his so
i never put it together that that was
his kid and that's his kid is i never
put it together that was his kid i mean
obviously the name is very obvious but
god bless you that's beautiful yeah
that's on my manifest list of course
because there's not a lot of there's no
not a lot of hyphen names on there
there's not
and i lived in hollywood 7225 my first
apartment out here look at us
look at that that is so awesome and i i
i would not uh i would i would not have
gone in literally not have gone in
without him going in like in san jose
almost oh he's not in but how much no
never mind and then that's like me being
like bobby needs a star and they'd be
like you're crazy
and then uh i did the same thing for
richard pryor
i i raised i helped raise the money
to to finish richard pryor statue in
peoria oh my god so i paid my my idols
uh back you have to because you don't
they influence you so much yeah like
what else is going to drive you you know
what people don't understand how much it
was
get driven by these people yeah it was
vital that that
it literally
puts a lump in my throat oh my god and i
was uh
and i was uh i was a kid man that
that had
i thought i had no opportunity
you know
and um
and i just respected them
i knew richard pryor
uh but also i just
thank them for it's almost like going
back and thanking a professor or
somebody that say listen man without you
no you were fine he's like no listen man
you don't understand without you i could
i could i could have done it without
bobby yeah in the night stalker case
the guy that gave me the education to
work it
i i had permission to bring him in
wait i'm putting this on wait wait wait
i'm putting this all together
now i'm recognizing you
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
so you worked on the night stalker case
yeah that was mike and you broke it yeah
holy [ __ ] gil i'm putting it all
together
he was the one that said it's
one guy it's one guy listen i'm obsessed
with that [ __ ] i am obsessed i can't get
enough why do women love murder stuff so
much because they want to [ __ ] kill
somebody no you know what it no it's not
that we like the details i like the
details and we like putting them
together we like he was the one that
said it's it's it's one person
and the guy that gave me that because i
could recognize him as a sexual tv was a
professor of mine at cal state la i had
the department's permission to bring him
in to help me out on the case he was on
sabbatical in greece we solved the case
got all the when he came back from
greece i got to go there and say
thank you
you gave me
the uh
working knowledge
to solve this case
will you tell her people sleep at night
better because of that oh will you tell
her the theory of what romance is
remember he said what's romantic to you
what sex is yeah yeah yeah what sex is
tell her i give you
uh i'm gonna give you a word i'm gonna
give you a definition the word is sex
the definition is whatever makes you
feel good so i give you a condo and
mammoth
no phones
no cell phones no law sex all right and
just you and that other member of
society you want to be with white bear
skin rug flickering fireplace snowing
outside no kids no nothing just just
music
whatever
wine wine whatever you want you're both
you and that other member of society
fresh out of the shower you sit down
there that's going to turn into what
you've already said a night of raw
unadulterated sex yes sexual interlude
extraordinaire
now i give you because that's sex to you
now i give you a man they can't afford
to go to mammoth but he's up in the
hills of malibu
he doesn't have
a battle a cabernet sauvignon but he's
got a bottle of white port in his back
pocket
he's not with another member of society
but he's got his own member in his own
hand he's got a book of matches without
a filtering fireplace he just set the
hills malibu on fire he's a pyromaniac
and now he's in an act of masturbation
oh my god because that is sex to him
so
when you realize sex is whatever makes
you feel good
in the contents of sexual deviation i
recognize that he was a sexual deviant i
could see things that were going on and
i got that knowledge from dr robert
morgan that is brilliant you know what
fascinates me why is that the sex he
loves like what made him like what i
think that's what we get fascinated by
like what created him in that way right
what you have to do is and the other
thing was his pinocchio don't smoke
[Laughter]
bob morneau says the other thing that i
learned from bob that was probably the
thing that has gotten me more
through anything is that is you have to
have the infinite amount of
understanding
understand don't condone
i understand what drove him i don't
condone it but i understand and if i
understand it it makes it easier for me
to talk to him when i talk to rich i
called him rich he called me gilman i
talked to him just like i'm talking to
you right now do you think that he was
responsible for all the stuff that
happened in the hotel
no
hotel do you think that was a whole
documentary that that was it
but i think it was [ __ ] you think it
was [ __ ] it was not very good yeah
it was not this hotel is more [ __ ] up
than that documentary made it out that
document played it safe yeah but he was
not explain to her the the the the
locker at the bus depot they he had a
lot of the yeah we called it his kill
kit he had a locker in the in the uh
greyhound busty pool right right right i
saw this on the deck
so he would go
put on we call it his kill kit he'd go
get dressed put on a skill kid go out
and
do his crimes go home get out and then
put it back in the locker room he would
go to he did not leave his kill kit at
the cecil because if he was away and
somebody said can you open that room and
then you go in there and you find
right knife or whatever right or his
whatever he took for the crime scene
so he put that kill kit at the greyhound
bus depot and locked it and he would go
into the bathroom and change into his
clothes we eventually found it we got a
search warrant we found him found the
kid unfortunately he's like he's kind of
hot for a serial killer okay not gonna
lie right
you know everybody says oh he looks so
debunked yeah uh sophie dickman 65 year
old surviving victim
uh she said he's quite the handsome
young he looks hot to me i'm like is
that [ __ ] up yeah no yeah i'm like
sometimes he drinks i would've been dead
you don't know they're a serial killer
until it's too late until you're dead if
you looked at him you know what would
you say to him if he was going to bang
you and then you're like hey what's the
[ __ ] you don't leave that rope i'm gonna
give you yeah i'm like hey babe what's
up he's like i gotta go to my locker
real quick i'm like it's over it's so
it's done hey maybe i'll go to my locker
yeah
uh but but um
explain the magnetism that he had uh
when people
people drew him from
all walks of life uh at one point in
time they had ugly women there was a
little bernadette it was a filipino
and she was in there every day during
preliminary hearing cute little gal
and then when he went from preliminary
here and then there was a few years in
between preliminary hearing and trial
she'd go visit him all the time and i
asked him one time i said hey whatever
happened to
bernadette and he says ah she tried to
talk me into going back into catholicism
and said last time i talked to her i
talked to her and now she's doing porno
oh you know so she's gotten into porno
so she's searching for something yeah
that's there was god then
yeah what about the people about the
attorneys the attorneys checking their
attorneys
they were dressed to the ten
had their little briefcases with them
gorgeous women
right out of a model magazine they were
gorgeous set right there and every time
richard walked in the courtroom he
walked in the first thing he did is he's
walking to his side of the
well where his defense table was he'd
scan
the courtroom
check out all the good looking guilt
yeah then he knew on his way out which
one he was going to focus on
and so as he's on his way out
these two ladies that were both
attorneys no doubt in my mind on the
right side of the lung and they were
sitting there on a corner on a corner
seat as he walked out he looked at them
smiled
one of them on the edge smiled back at
him
blew him a kiss and opened up her legs
yeah
and i i saw this because they had called
me to the phone bail i was using the
baylo's phone and i'm looking at this i
just put the phone down he went out i
went back and told my partner i said
[ __ ] hook me up see if anybody comes
like that visiting me
i mean she was they were they were
gorgeous
why i have no idea
what's the what's the job what is that
and you know what before then like
nobody understood what the idea of
a trigger was to whatever somebody's
behavior right yeah i want to trigger
no trigger is like a big thing now right
yeah yeah but nobody knew what a trigger
would have been
to somebody like that guy um um
rodney akala the serial killer was
driving he saw a little girl walking
home by herself and that was his i think
something happened in his childhood i i
sat there and i an
analogy
i sat there and used the analogy of
richard and he did as we talked to him
he would sit there
and think about tonight's tonight i'm
going to go out and caper tonight so
he'd sit there and he was he was digging
it so that's what it was it was like he
they became his he was smoking his weed
he was a weed smoker loved cocaine
yeah he was just telling his eyes he'd
smoke some dope i love okay
to now like in my body
it's the knight
you go up put the kill kit on go do his
dash little bead and then that is a
anti-social act you know it's an
irrational act the killing but then it's
followed by acts of rationality which
means okay now i gotta get rid of all
this stuff and i gotta hide so they
don't catch me so yeah so he's not loot
he's not he's in a lucid state when he's
doing it so he's very aware right so
then it's his sex you pick you picture
a female
that's gonna go out tonight
or a male and she's like i just love i
just hope he likes my hair and so now
he's thinking about killing and you're
like my eyeliner like here here's a guy
that's married to sitting there
tonight's the night i'm gonna go out and
cheat so he's thinking about it all
night
and now okay now i'm gonna go out so now
he goes out and he builds up and he goes
out and he hits that lady
now he's done hitting the lady now he's
on his way back and now that's
an act that he shouldn't be doing so now
he's all the way back he's okay now how
do i cover it up that's the same thing
richard was doing just to a different
degree that is so good and it's almost
like you know what once once he got in
his kill kit to go out
he didn't want to come back without
accomplishing it's like going out and
coming back you know like you don't do a
set yeah
yeah and there were times where you
didn't accomplish everything you wanted
and so you go from one location to
another another yeah you know my thing
listening to these true crimes because i
do it almost on a daily basis is just
the mispractice of like in the 80s and
90s of so many police like there's just
so much like negligence and like things
like people not believing someone's
actually missing there's a hindsight
because there was no dna no dna testing
in the 80s right i i still love
cops today sit there and say god i don't
understand how you solved it because of
the lack of scientific evidence that you
have but it is so fit it is
psychological and if you can if you can
track somebody's psychological pattern i
mean you know it's brilliant to do it
that way so
you know what detectives used to do that
i don't think they do now
is they would go to the autopsy
and they would stand there and wait and
a lot of people get make autopsy they're
paid off or they they'll like rule
something weird on the autopsy
you know
uh depending on where you go you know
people don't understand people may
that's what made the cecil hotel such a
piece of
in my opinion garbage well because it
was like well and not only that
i mean
they asked me to be part of the project
in the beginning and i turned them down
yeah and and they'd ask people on the
street what do you think well i think
lapd is hiding information i think
they're lying they're doing just people
that know nothing about the business
when you go to the coroner's office i'll
speak only of los angeles county and
orange county yeah the only two that
i've attended they don't hide anything
you know they're two separate entities
we don't but they don't know what's
happening look at the places look at
these tiny towns right where everybody
knows each other exactly i found out a
kid that who's a murderer is a kid of
somebody famous
friend of mine that you've met
uh
vidal herrera
1 800 autopsy he just called me up the
other day to tell me
he does the second he does the second
scene they picked up a program they're
going to do it
they they just picked him last week he
called me up fascinated by that's going
to do a thing on his life right there
that's incredible
oh yeah how many dead body have you seen
a buddy ever
i've only seen one you know you know
videl invited me to go to see a autopsy
and i just at the last minute i decided
i think i want to
i think i want to do it he's here i'm
going to go yeah i'm gonna i would like
to is that weird i can hook it up there
it is i saw one guy on eighth he had
just gotten shot and he was on the
ground and i saw and i have to admit is
he dead he was dead i could i see it
still very vividly so maybe it is a bad
idea to see that
you didn't come or anything you didn't i
wasn't like no no
because it's just something i just am
fascinated by the whole thing and
fascinated by like finding what happened
to somebody's body and like telling a
story from it like but is that new or
not i think
i don't know is it no i've always been
fascinated by murder stuff always ever
since i was a little kid i was like i
remember when our we our birds died and
we bury them and then like i like a
month later we went big we we dug it up
yeah we dug it up i never was i i became
fascinated with investigation murder
investigations when i was a young cop
seeing the way how professional they
were and how diligent they were and how
they worked so hard how everybody got
out of the way for them they were creme
de la creme
that's what i wanted okay will you tell
her about when you asked your family to
leave the house and the phone rang and
three of the morning well they they i
didn't ask them to leave my wife told me
so so during the investigation
um i worked in northridge and he was
killing people north oh okay
i worked during the day in the 80s
but
when when richard ramirez was out there
that's you guys have known each other no
no we met a couple years ago but the
thing is that when we were working
during the day and he was loose he was
still loose
the minute the sun was going down you
could [ __ ] feel the fear a fear in in
the air like you could feel like
everybody would
nobody went to the grocery store like i
[ __ ] got to get home
the in the in the in the documentary the
grand the grandparents he was coping he
was covered the grandparents left the
thing open and they went the girl went
over to say hey grandma grandpa you got
to lock the doors ah nothing he struck
and um
uh
and he hit even when you thought that
this guy can't be consid and he and he
kept hitting
so how many people did he kill he we
filed 14 counts of murder but there was
multiple more well
we thought they were we looked at eight
more cases but they were they were all
circumstantial so we didn't add them but
also you don't want to think that he's
starting to target the detectives so his
family moved they moved out of his house
right yeah because he because they moved
out
we found that
he uh eventually when he was in custody
he said he knew where i lived
and that was after his arrest but
the week before his arrest we'd been
down to
orange county
in
on one of the cases and when i came back
i found footprints around my house it
didn't belong there oh my god and so we
ended up for the last week we had
surveillance on my house you know giving
me
protection it was him and he said he
knew where i was but that's not even
really his mo though right to like
target certain people like it wasn't his
whole thing like a young like a girl who
i like we don't know it was a real
changes it was
a hollywood thing yeah anything and
everything there was no
mo as you say right he that's why when
they
sent criminal profilers from quantico
virginia out here they said hey this is
a crapshoot we've never had anybody in
criminal history doing what you're
alleging he's doing and he did it
and so bottom line it would have been a
featherless cap had he got somebody
somebody in the investigation yeah he'd
have gotten mine
and he knew who he was somebody in your
family yeah it would have been cool and
he had changed shoes by then because
feinstein had made public she made a
public statement about it and
she publicly said what you have yeah i
remember seeing that he got rid of the
shoes he got rid of the gun he one of
the guns he threw over the
golden gate bridge and so it was it was
it was just it was and and then
it was three o'clock in the morning and
you were were you up or you were you
know i was asleep when they called me up
when i woke up but but also you were he
was going door to door i woke up i woke
up in a cold sweat i'm nervous yeah my
stomach i'm nauseated subconsciously
no no totally yet almost
it's sort of the area yeah yeah
so i get up i grab my gut and i clear my
house i clear my house awesome laughter
very familiar
as if there were burglaries so he's
clearing his house so he's going
with your back against the wall like the
door like and then to another one yeah
back into the wall with the with the gun
up and what happens and i couldn't call
the cops because the cops
were from my department if i called them
and there's nobody here they're going to
sit there and say okay he's going off
the [ __ ] deep end now
oh i see you're trying to [ __ ] hear
things so
i'm clearing my own house i get back in
my room i'm nauseated i'm sweating yeah
get back i turn on tv john wayne movie
is on channel five and all of a sudden
it's 3 30 in the morning and the [ __ ]
phone rings
that's when i got children
you know
imagine that imagine that in the middle
of the night and so you're watching the
[ __ ]
my family was spending very little time
at my house at this time they were down
with my in-laws
and
they called me up from the office and
said hey call linda arthur who was in
the documentary
and he said call her up so i called her
up she's very dear friend of mine her
husband had been murdered on june 1st of
that same year this is now a month later
and
i went through the academy with him we
were very good friends
so she called me up and she worked our
latent print section at the time she'd
been out on something section latent
prince
these are the criminals
they go out and take fingerprints take
pictures prince okay okay okay remember
they would put tape over it and then
yeah lift the thing yeah so they go out
she'd been out on some of the murders
with me
so they said call her up i call her up
and she says gil i think you ought to
come down here
lady across the street from me has just
been raped and i think it's part of what
you're working on
now i'm looking across the street from
your house from her house but around in
the hood
so he's coming for her too or is it
gone to this random lady's house and he
had raped her now
when all this is going on the first
thing i do is i look at my
like a good
homicide cop like a nurse
somebody that's important when something
goes down first thing you do is what
time is it
right of town right keep track of things
yeah so i looked 3 30 in the morning i
just got back in my bed turned he'd be
on 3 30 in the morning i'm saying
what the [ __ ] is he doing right now he's
[ __ ] with me it's [ __ ] with my
life now the phone ring she says come on
down she just got raped
she will tell us she will testify
because as it turns out
he did rape her right across the street
from
linda arthur's house who was a deputy
working the case
and and her husband was a [ __ ] law
enforcer her husband had been killed
murder the murdered the month before
and so she cannot catch a break this
year yeah so
we we went everything's right she'll
testify
that at 3 30 in the morning he was
sodomizing her
oh my god meanwhile we're like but i
don't got to write a funny joke
so
it was a lot of well i should have hated
you yeah yeah like should we eat before
my set or not like wow that's um i mean
imagine and no phones no social media no
which would gave it more which gave the
darkness the more it's harder to find
people
but nowadays you feel like it's harder
to get away with crimes because there is
so much security everywhere cameras
everywhere social media or no no i i
don't believe in in my heart of hearts
no it's not yeah all that happens is
criminals become
much better at hiding they you might be
the first [ __ ] latino that's ever
used the term heart of hearts too
because nobody says that
hey what the [ __ ] hey
in my heart of hearts
hey bro [ __ ] in my heart of hearts
that's it i'm so
no barely that's up for the truth eh all
my stand up was all that [ __ ] that i
would hear like i was at the airport and
they would be like hey [ __ ] where you
been [ __ ] i barely got here you know
burley
burley
where you can learn so that way so so
for me
as a crime enthusiast i live i lived you
know i studied it right you're even
surprised how much i know about crap i
think i'd really be surprised how much
you know about crime i know i like
literally it's all i listen to and my
friends are like why do i listen to it
before i go to bed i'm just so
fascinated
truly yeah and i'm not kissing his ass
he never ceases to make
true crime
sports
boxing baseball i feel like those are
all kind of the same you know you can't
do different sports like they're all
that different i never
you know panocha
you watch reality vietnam
i i follow my daughters but i'm not into
big sports and everything
but this guy knows everything you're
dodgers i love how la you are you're so
cute you've done it so much for the city
i love it
uh
he could still be around killing people
i can tell you this right now
october 1st i just got notified
i'm being uh asked i'm being honored
at the galaxy soccer football
thing halftime oh
local hometown hero
oh no i go down at halftime and they're
saying for everything that i've done uh
in the armed forces you know going to
vietnam
and and what i did in vietnam
getting done
what i did and what what i did i'm gonna
break your heart in 31 days
and uh that's my soccer case so i get to
go down there
they're out inviting me down and are you
retired are you still yeah i'm retired
lucky but he's he's he's very busy now
you know but are you retired and then
kind of like still is there a case that
like this is gonna we're gonna try to
solve a murder
wait i'm fascinated by all of this but i
i
i have so many questions are there are
there is there something in your career
that you didn't close that still bothers
you like is there a case that got away
yes yes what is that first one that
comes with the first swing that comes to
mind there's a case in uh
out of uh
[ __ ] i can't remember where the when
you're staying
yeah this is a good beer by the way
it really is yeah
uh there's a case where the lady there's
no doubt in my mind she killed her
husband
and i can't prove it
let's get her cameras
tell me her name after i'm going to
start stopping
i know she give her the insurance
company came after me her and because
they wanted to pay
you know the death isn't that number one
thing they said
they've fallen are you going to
you know you
did you follow christopher watts case no
oh i'm obsessed with true crime uh this
thing called or uh crime junkie that's
what i listen to oh it's a podcast but
who's going to say her name or anything
yeah i told her an insurance company i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what
you're calling her a suspect i said yes
i am it's well you're going to file okay
i said i don't have enough to file on
her right now well then you're gonna
have to change your things we want to
pay her i said you do whatever you want
to it's your money i ain't changing my
thing she's my suspect
this is well we'll sue you i said sue me
i don't care we got lawyers
what is it why would they sue you i
don't unders
because of alleged i'm holding i'm using
her
and she won't be paid the insurance
benefits as long as she's assessment
well that's what she gets for killing
her husband alleged
allegedly you know as a young boy um
you know charles manson
in his last interview
yeah a guy that would write
uh
murder serial killer books
went to visit charles madison at the
soledad prison and he said to him
so how do you spend your your time these
days because he was he was old he said
well you know i love classic rock
this this might be on my head so
i love classic rock also i'm a huge fan
of
frank sinatra john wayne and george
lopez
shut the [ __ ] up
that is [ __ ] crazy
don't quote charles manson on your grave
first of all oh but we're gonna talk
about butterfly wings down there and all
that okay no but i mean uh no
butterflies
the bacardi bat flying around but but uh
but that it's that's pretty crazy i mean
it's not it's not a compliment that you
but it's pretty good it's really cool
somebody said they're gonna go care who
my fans are as long as they're fans i
don't care it's a secret but now went
out to millions of people all around the
world no i know i mean it's like
i mean it's i mean it's not my hey his
we we're never but he's the guy comedy
was never in question it was just his
taste in life you know what i mean and
whether he wanted
the second day he was there the first
thing i'm going to tell you something
right now i've never said this on on the
show before i am a pfc
that's something
first class oh yeah so
but there are two people
in my life that i said just hey
say a little prayer for their soul oh
and who are they me
richard ramirez
and charlie manson charlie manson
two most vile people in the [ __ ]
world
and charles manson childhood was [ __ ]
up
his mom was a writer you know producers
all these people they've asked
but why why do they ask me on the
netflix thing you know they they
and they put it on there but they asked
me why do you why do you do that well
you didn't know charles massey weren't
connected no no
because i said
nobody else is doing that for him and if
anybody needs a little help
i'm not praying you know don't let him
out you know [ __ ] keep them wherever
you want to i'm just saying if anybody
needs it they do
and it's just for their soul god bless
them you know i
i don't care they never bought me a
drink no bought me anything i don't give
a [ __ ] i will say you're one of the few
people with three names who does not
kill for a living
so i mean i hope i kill
you
um there's so many cases i want to ask
you about what about the grandma who
kept all the bodies underneath dorothea
puente
california
yeah that's ice and when she said oh he
went to go visit family yeah
yeah yeah what family what about what
about juan corona the farm worker that
was killing uh
from mexico
you don't hear a lot of juan corona yeah
that would be a good the one corona
movie would be good because it's good he
was a migrant worker that was a [ __ ]
serial killer burying the bodies out
where they grew the crops in the white
people's fields that's great and then
we're all eating it we're all eating
nobody knows about juan corona everybody
forgot about one girl yeah they need to
do more stuff
with the documentary the girl from the
picture
where the dad this guy kidnapped this
girl pretended like he was her father
for years and years and years and then
that's right yeah and then he like and
then killed her and then killed multiple
other people and then finally found him
but he had all these different aliases
the girl from the picture and they just
came out the documentary just came out
i'm fascinated by this stuff do
i used to have one called jaded i only
21 episodes i got lazy i didn't have
someone producing it and stuff so i just
got lazy and i was like oh i don't need
to do it you don't miss doing it i miss
doing it like if they if hey if alc took
me on i would do it but i was like
editing myself doing all this stuff
i'll tell you right now everything i've
done in life
from
the investigations the murder the you
know the netflix thing
this is the most fun i've ever had
look at that he's having more fun here
instead of catching us
that's so crazy you mean this is more
fun than
catching murder do you know that that
this is the latino symbol for somebody
who's kissing ass what oh that's oh no
because that's the actual
brown and here you are you just go like
this hey what's that what's her
boyfriend like no he loves it
somebody won't tip
when he did this
what was this called no do you know what
this is called
no anybody else
aaron doesn't know
what is it
i like the anticipation i'm not going to
tell you guys
if you guys tune in if you guys tune
into hotties
yes
how many holidays have been filmed
already we're done
before
it was it was filmed years ago now it
was filmed last year
you know um it's funny to say that you
know when chico and the man was uh on at
the end of the show freddie prinz would
say
chico the man was filled in front of a
live audience at burbank studio nbc stu
is burbank
california and when i was doing my show
they said to me will you say george
lopez was filming a live audience
i love that i can't wait to be on i just
want to be on a sitcom that's all i want
that's
cool here's what i see for you like as a
as a
i see us
producing a show for peacock about with
stand-ups
that are
that that aren't in the alternative
rooms but that because that are on the
fringe
that don't want to fall into alternative
that that because it's showing you
comedy because
everybody wants to show comedy where
everybody's great but let's show some
comedy where people have to think
maybe it's because i'm wearing my carlos
antenna
i love that
have you are you friends with him yeah
did you guys hang out today gave me this
guy hi all the cool all the people i
want to know you know them all hi hello
hi hi
how is that how he is yeah he's like
and you're like hi you like that idea
and we're doing it for people yeah i
love that idea i love that idea i went
to brazil you host it and you finally
yeah you find them i went to brazil uh
like a few years back before covet to
try stand up in portuguese for the first
time because it's booming there like
millions of people go out to see comedy
there because there's not a lot of tv
most stuff is social media you're that
fluent in it yeah i'm fluent
and
people are talking so fast portuguese
i'm like what are they saying but i i
did it i ate [ __ ] like the first
probably seven times and then by nine
and ten you know i'm starting to
understand how to do it but it's
different there the comedy's still like
where it was here in the 80s it's still
very observational and or copied from
american comics you know what i mean
i'm like i know all these bands i know
all these bets i'm big in mexico but
it's not me saying the word exactly
and because i you know it's just a weird
it's just a different place like i would
do stand up i would do like audience
work and people would be like but you
know how [ __ ] hard but you know how
[ __ ] hard that is like it was hard it
was but it was so beautiful for me
because it gave me such a power i was
like i am brazilian because you know
people are like well you didn't grow up
there fully i'm like but that's that's
who i am that's who i am and so being
around people like me i was like see i
see i am that's yeah that it really is
that's a powerful yeah and i filmed a
documentary so i filmed the whole thing
i've been trying to sell it for like
three years let's see we can sell it
it's beautiful let's see if we can i'll
show it to you it's called foreign are
we uh are we good
i'm kind of tipsy from this one that is
called foreign
who are you texting who's that hot girl
that popped up in your i saw it i saw a
photo
yeah it popped up
some pistols see all i did was look at
my watch because it vibrated and he says
oh
do you know that brazilian model actress
bruno bruno you can't just say bruno
that's like every other girl's name it
is [ __ ] every other yeah it's like
a young actress uh
is she a comic too no actress bruno
she's in blue beetle
what's that
a dc movie that we just did oh no way um
no i don't know her i don't know a lot
of brazilian actresses but i know a lot
of comics
let's see
oh yeah i know of her i don't know her
personally but we could be we could be
siblings yeah um what a fun like how did
you guys meet how did you guys come
together
come on
you found me underneath your bridge push
it i just [ __ ] you just saw you
eating a doughnut in your car and you're
like let's see you know the sixth street
bridge no he came in as a
my publicist said to me have you seen
the nightstalker uh
docu-series it was released in january
and i said no i haven't only playing
stupid i already seen it like four times
in a row
and and then i called the number i found
who did i called uh put it on i called
his partner
you you put it yeah you called my
partner first frankfurter no and said
hey
what's his name frank salerno that's the
most cop name i've ever heard frank
sorry he gave me the message hey george
wants to talk to you so i
called him up
and i think all white girl names could
be porn never never heard from him he
said he called me back susan williams
spam called
you know hey there's gilbert there i
said who is it what do you want and he
hung up a [ __ ] booth
next thing i know i have another friend
of mine that called me up says hey i
just heard george
uh on the radio saying anybody know gail
carrell here's never have him call up
so i called him
next thing you know we're talking 35 45
minutes first time he invited me out
golfing i said i don't golf oh yeah
you're an avid golfer yeah and he says
how about a beer with friends i said
that
i do yeah
came in here i had no idea this was what
it was
wow and that's what started uh every
every week murders and comics are we the
same kind of people yeah
i think they are i think yeah
it's more it's a psychological it's a
it's a behavior and it's when no one's
looking like we do our best work when no
one's looking even though
we will stand and have people look at us
the processes don't look at the process
but the only time i feel free is when
i'm on stage you think it's the only
time my brain isn't like do you think we
were both pansexuals we would have
[ __ ] already oh yeah i think we would
have i mean you just got to be gay for
that
you don't have to go all the way
all right i love you i i do we just bet
it i love you i love you i'm such a fan
thank you for having me awesome
yeah you guys are great i'm going to
pick your brain after this i can't wait
i'm going oh boy
i think you should there's a there's a
knife episode of this one there's a guy
that killed this girl and i know it and
i know it in my gut and i know it and
we'll talk about it afterwards but they
ruled it a suicide but it's not
no [ __ ] way there's a lot of those
yeah what about the one the girl that
was ashley kutcher's girlfriend and he
went
and it was the guy that lived around him
that guy
and asked him could kutcher went and
knocked on the door and looked inside he
saw like he thought it was wine you know
he's like oh yeah and he left they were
they were gonna date and it was it was a
[ __ ] dude that came bernie murphy too
brittany murphy too that whole thing is
[ __ ] weird right
that thing is weird
pretty much everything is weird yeah the
mom and the mom and the mama
and the dude died too and then the dude
died why not
simon uh
that whole thing him is sleeping in the
bed with the mom after
i can't get over i can't i keep thinking
because i have ocd so then after i watch
this [ __ ] i can't stop thinking about it
oh i can't wait you're sick that's sick
i'm gonna be texting you all times of
the night
i'm cold sorry yeah uh but that's that's
[ __ ] sick i mean that really is sick
of the chickens in the eye of the
beholder
exactly see
maybe that's his thing that's what he
does that's his sex but thank you for
having me on i [ __ ] old lady one time
yep same and then the band you don't
have to take her home
you [ __ ] old man
i thought you [ __ ] an old lady no i
[ __ ] an old lady but you know what
yeah i mean old and old i'm old for me
but
by my age
no
i mean old men your age are regular i
went on a date with a with a with a
with a woman last week
okay
great sir i feel very old-fashioned
i like you why am i blowing a dude in
here
let's pick this
this [ __ ] thing is dragging
dates are so boring your uh
hoodies what's it called hotties hotties
potties
august 26 and then my special drops on
youtube august 28th jaded
yes thank you that's very sweet i'm very
excited it's all the material i wrote
and been doing for what i mean helium no
we i filmed it at the helium in
philadelphia oh so they're releasing it
they're releasing 12 different specials
and i'm just i'm one of them yeah
best one where can people see you live
can we see you and i'm at the comedy
store every week so come catch me there
la factory improv all the good stuff and
i've been at comedy and magic you got to
come into a show with me at the live
factory i would love that okay i'm there
a lot i love it there like a ruby
tuesday where you sell those out yeah
well i haven't heard that name in a
while
i get to go i do all right yeah
all right
we saw that we saw the girl calling in
you do good you're doing good you got
your own beer you got your own sitcom
you know you know carlos santana you
smoked with cheese and [ __ ] yeah
i love how like he's become very yogi
huh that's like a very lotus yogi shirt
that's what i said
two hours of this not kissing his ass
but you know when you're
when i was younger i'd play softball
a lot of side play softball four days a
week different games yeah
and so when you're not baseball
specifically the female one okay so
oh man you guys were like that hurt how
about the balls bigger so you could be
like
let me pull why socks how about the
balls
not fastball where the ball is smaller
so you're like [ __ ]
all right so you're playing so you're
playing softball how are we doing not on
that field yeah and for an hour and ten
minutes to two hours you think of
nothing else other than that stand up
for us that's standard for you okay
nothing else in the world matters i
don't care what happens when i come in
here i don't give a [ __ ] about anything
else that's going out people are just
killing outside and we're like
walking in front of them
it's fun in here not today it's fun in
here
but also i always i felt like
because he had he had retired from being
a sheriff that
there's i mean this guy's a knowledge of
[ __ ] and i always say it in different
podcasts
like people that
that retire because of mandatory
retirement or whatever
there's no replacement for experience
he's got it all the softball games you
played
two outs guard the line
how about that one two outs guard the
line that's it
all right you're awesome thank you guys
so much
you